Chiefs last year got to the brink of the
Super Bowl lost at home in the AFC
Championship game in overtime to the
Patriots now trying to get back to that
level and one step farther and Chris
look major changes defensively Bob
Sutton out as defensive coordinator
Steve spagnolo in a shift from a
three-four to a 4 3 D Ford gets traded
out from under the franchise tag they
trade for Frank Clark new pass rusher
from under the franchise tag in Seattle
and that's just the the biggest move I
mean Tyrann Mathieu in there as well
they're doing what they can to make that
defense better we talked so much about
the Chiefs of offense but the question
is can spagnolo make that defense better
and it doesn't have to be a lot better
just a little better could be all the
difference in the world for the Kansas
City Chiefs in 2019 yeah that's right
don't be 31st in football don't be
second-to-last and run game and pass
defense I mean you're right if they get
up to even to the the low 20s the high
teens it'll change their team around it
won't put as much pressure on their
offense all the time you know Mike you
made the point and I think that's where
I'd like to start that defense this
scheme change I think that will be
important
you know Bob Sutton did some good things
there but I always thought there was a
few little issues with their scheme
altogether whether I had problems the
way it's coached or sometimes they did
things unrealistically but I think with
Spagnola there I do think some things
will improve there and they're getting
bigger up front I think they said the
heck with all these pass rushers you
said they traded from Frank Clark not
only is he good at rushing the passer
he's phenomenal against the run traded
for a manual akbah from the Cleveland
Browns another guy who's just big and
physical sign Alex Okafor as a free
agent
another guy who's big and physical on
the edge of the defense so they've kind
of changed what they their mantra is on
the defensive side of the ball and you
said Tyra and Matthew I like that the
secondary still has some issues
tyro Matthew certainly helps safety
position nickel position and I thought
one of the better signings they had was
basalt breelan but Shawn Breeland if
anybody remembers was about to sign a
huge deal last year in free agency there
was some issues found in his physical
about you know foot issues and then he
decided he had a sign basically a
one-year deal and wasn't quite himself
at the start of the
and really kind of didn't get going to
the end of the year or whatever it may
be but they got a guy there oh I think
has potential to help the team out so
the defense I expect to be better but
damn mic they lost Tiree kill and
they're not gonna have them this year or
they shouldn't and that is Hugh yeah we
we still don't know what's gonna happen
at time we kill the Chiefs haven't done
anything haven't said much since two
weeks ago when he was essentially
suspended from offseason activities the
NFL to this day has still not even
acknowledged the audio that came out 13
days ago the troubling audio where Tyree
killed threatens and menaces crystal
espen all a person he admitted to
choking and beating while pregnant five
years ago so it doesn't look good for
Tyree kill they drafted me call Hardman
who does a lot of the things that he'll
does which may be an indication that
he'll is not going to be there much
longer if at all one move on offense
Kris cuz the defense look they've got a
lot of recognizable names out
recognizable names in offensively Mitch
Morse one of the best centers in
football is gone what does that do to
Patrick my Holmes what kind of pressure
does that put on him and the offensive
line asthma Holmes tries to replicate
what he did last year yeah I mean scent
are so important because not only is he
orchestrating everything at the line of
scrimmage I mean Mitch Morris arguably
is the best center in football so yeah
they're gonna miss that aspect of a guy
who can handle awesome defensive tackles
all by himself they don't have to worry
about that Mitch Morris was phenomenal
athlete in the second level but
offensive line is one thing I don't
worry about a whole lot with Andy Reid
football teams you talk about like we
talked about how certain teams have an
eye for certain positions we talked
about the Steelers with wide receivers
right man I look at Andy Reid and just
go gosh he's got the eye for offensive
lineman it's what I'm always scared
about evaluating their football team
because I always wonder if there's guys
up coming up the ranks that we don't
know about that he's got faith in so I
think the offensive line will still be
good it's really just gonna be about Ken
McCall Hardman somebody else report
their second-round pick replace the
explosiveness that Tyree kil brought to
the offense and also when you've got a
Patrick mahomes you can make things
happen when everything collapses d even
need blockers maybe you Tom
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports